well the Democratic primary electorate
includes millions of african-american
and Hispanic voters and according to the
press the geniuses on cable news the
racists because not enough of them have
backed african-american candidates watch
this a stage for the Democratic Party
that is all white is not a stage that
the Democrats should be proud of in 2020
and with Booker dropping out this
contest becomes much more white it was
taught for Cory Booker to get beyond
poor percent just like it was tough for
Camilla Harris and others the voters
here don't look like the voters and the
rest of the electorate in the country
and it's a tougher race for them the way
they've set up the primary order of
states is a bad idea
based upon lily-white states that don't
reflect the Democratic Party there's
really a lot of ways to win this
presidential election for Democrats and
it's not just getting all those crusty
white guys in diners in you know the
Midwest nothing against top guys in
diners in the Midwest I swear the Trump
campaign is paying that woman she's just
an ad for Trump Dave Rubin joints out
the Rubin report on YouTube our old
friend joins us here on set Dave great
to see it tonight it's good to see you
before you say anything Tucker I just
want to be very clear the woman you're
talking about right there
clip that's Jennifer Rubin I am in no
way related actually she's a plan jeb
Bush's former spokeswoman who's on MSNBC
you watch somebody like you know what
I'm voting for Trump I don't care it's
unbelievable anyway we ask you how
dehumanizing do you think it is to see
people in the media who appear intent on
dividing the country along racial lines
to dismiss people on the base of their
skin color look how did we get to this
place who was that guy that wanted his
children not to be judged by the color
of their skin of their character that
guy was kind of right that guy MLK jr.
obviously he was a liberal he was a
liberal but the progressives have
nothing to do with true liberalism and
there's a hilarity going on here because
for years they've been screaming that
all of us anyone who's not a woke
intersectional progressive is a racist
but what was going to be at the end
rohde of that at the end of the road is
exactly what's happening right now
they would have to turn it on themselves
and now they are turning it on
themselves so MSNBC is now putting up
people to basically say forget those
Republicans and conservatives and Trump
supporters that are racists we're the
racists because in an hour from right
now there's gonna be a democratic debate
I think it's on CNN and guess what's
gonna happen it's gonna be all white
people thank God Elizabeth is one 1024
it's a Native American or whatever it is
I don't know what happened Andrea he
should be in there but his Asian Asst
doesn't even count right because Asian
doesn't sort of fit into the
intersectional calculator so this is
this is the end game of what all of
these competing what they're really
doing is I think you're suggesting if
you want to be precise Mathare blaming
black voters I mean there's a reason the
Ordinaries and lakhs aren't supporting
their own I mean think how insane
they're turning to the african-american
elector of the Democratic Party is
saying you're bigots yeah rich people on
MSNBC people like the I can't remember
her name with the woman you shared last
thing with Jennifer Rubin yeah that's
what they're doing yeah well you may
remember that at the State of the Union
last year when President Trump said we
have the lowest all-time black line
employment and the cameras flashed to
the Congressional Black Caucus and they
sat there like this now if you cared
about your country if you cared about
black people or just citizens of your
country wouldn't you be happy that they
have low unemployment that would be good
but if you're a partisan hack then you
wouldn't care about that and I think
most people are waking up to this stuff
I mean it's I sent out a tweet at the
beginning on January 1st saying this is
the year of the implosion of this thing
of woken is it has to implode now
because Elizabeth has to call Bernie a
misogynist and someone else has to call
Bernie a racist because that's all they
got because they can't they can't debate
on policy they can't really debate on
taxes or foreign policy or any of these
things so they have to get you on all of
these things because it's sort of worked
in a lot of ways against conservatives
right you're one of the few guys that
consistently stands up against it but
it's silence is a lot of people and I
think this is I think this is the year
that it it just they've cried wolf
reaches the pole
I look at suggest that really nobody is
for this crap other than a very tiny
percentage of MSNBC hosts for example
but like your average person of all any
color doesn't like this car nobody cares
it's it's an anthem and it's a reverse
of what the American Dream is nobody
cares what your skin color is nobody
cares what your gender is or even your
sexuality or any of these things if
you're an American and you live by the
laws of America and yeah and you work
hard and and try to better your life and
your family's life that's what this
whole thing is about but why do they
never talk about that why do they why
are they afraid to say words like
liberty and freedom imagine that imagine
those you know who said those words
tulsi gabbard said it now she's out of
they hate her right yeah I I can't wait
till these are the worst people I've
ever dealt with and and I can't wait
till they're gone dude we've been great
to see you good to see a man if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell